cuando hice el vídeo acerca de funciones
pares y funciones impares hice el
comentario desafortunado de que no había
una conexión directa entre las funciones
pares y los números pares y tampoco
entre las funciones impares y los
números impares eso es erróneo y quiero
aprovechar este vídeo para corregirlo y
explorar cuál es la conexión
antes que nada veamos que cuando hable
de funciones pares desde el ejemplo
clásico de fx igual x al cuadrado y
cuando hable de funciones impares y el
ejemplo de x al cubo y posteriormente
incluso dije que también podía ser f x
de fx igual a equis y esos eran ejemplos
de funciones impares así que ustedes
quizás ya empiezan a notar una relación
entre los exponentes de x y el tipo de
función que es ahora quiero ser muy
claro no todas las funciones pares
surgen como cosas de la forma x al
cuadrado o de la forma x al cubo o f x
igual a x hay funciones por ejemplo las
trigonométricas que pueden ser pares o
impares sin ni siquiera involucrar a x
elevado alguna potencia por ejemplo el
coste de x que esta gráfica do aquí el
coseno dx es una función par y el seno
de x es una función impar pero ninguno
de ellos parece x elevado a alguna
potencia
veamos
si yo digo
fx es igual a equis solo x x a la 1
entonces esto es una función impar
si digo que fx es igual a x al cuadrado
entonces es una función par
y si digo que fx es igual a x al cubo
entonces de nuevo tengo una función
impar así que aquí quizás ya esté
notando una relación entre el exponente
y la paridad de la función si el
exponente es impar la función es impar
pero tiene que ser x al algo no puede
involucrar a más términos porque por
ejemplo vimos aquí que x al cubo más 1
es un ejemplo de una función que no es
para ni impar a pesar de que la potencia
la que estoy elevando la x es una
potencia impar
así que si quiero que usar este criterio
sólo puede ser fx igual a x algo es más
de que me lo noto así si defino fx igual
a x a la n entonces esta función va a
ser una función impar
impar
si n es impar y m es impar
iba a ser una función par
función
presión par si n
par y de nuevo quiero ser muy enfático
no todas las funciones pares o impares
son algo de esta forma como les decía
las funciones trigonométricas a veces
también son pares o impares y
definitivamente no son de la forma f x
igual a x a la n así que no todas las
funciones parecen pares salen de este
modo algunas funciones ni siquiera
tienen nada que ver con polinomios por
ejemplo esta y aún así podemos
clasificarlas en funciones pares y
funciones impares lo que pasa es que
podemos decir que este tipo de funciones
por ejemplo el coste en ode x tiene la
misma simetría alrededor del eje y que
la función f x igual a x al cuadrado por
eso las agrupamos todas juntas y
hablamos de las funciones pares del
mismo modo las funciones que tienen la
misma simetría alrededor del eje jay del
eje x que x al cubo a esas las llamamos
funciones impares así que pues si existe
esa conexión les digo aquí está quizás
esto es en lo que se inspiraron para
definir a las funciones pares